so
so he's not walking around
me right
keep your arm where you are and go
that way you get it so
the way i keep him with me is
i keep pushing this arm like that
so as he tries to go i keep moving it
forward
he tries to go that way i keep moving it
okay so this arm goes here
and then you're gonna you're gonna lose
you're gonna lose it at a certain point
and in the yin young world that's where
the other arm comes
so who is doing that
is not him following me
i'm on the inside of the curve i'm on
the inside of that
comes in
that's where the other hand comes up and
does the same thing
oh
[Music]
so this this is inherited you have to
understand
that as as i uh swing him around
there's a vertical energy
and i can by being
on the inside on a slightly
angled axis of rotation
you send triple the energy centripetal
energy
in a progressive manner where he
gets stuck to me okay so
it's not that i'm back here and i'm
gonna pull this hand
nor is it that he he walks around me
see that's still
there i'm going to be here
my my energy is coming into me
this that generates this centripetal
energy
and that's what i lock on
and then i replace it once i get on the
other side of the circle
this you're going to see what happens is
this hand gets me
my axis rotation too far outside but the
other hand picks it up
whoa
this is the same thing you're doing in
this technique here i'm not
hooking him he's trying to go straight
but i'm doing the same thing with his
head
i'm not pulling it but it creates
that kind of axis of rotation the same
thing here
one two three
[Music]
i'm on the other side and then pushing
him forward
[Music]
my hair
it's not that my hand goes like this i
don't want to shrink this angle here
my hand does move over here but it's
because my hip moved over here
good same angle
i'm going to step if i step and leave my
hand where it is i did the same mistake
so as i step the hand has to keep moving
the hand has to keep moving
so hip moves hip moved again
and i'm going forward so if you pay
attention to my hands they're not going
in and out
oh hip step
turn it's going to go straight because
my hips going to turn
i'm going to go this way
the same thing i've been here repaint my
hands aren't going like this
my hip move my hand came up
my hips gonna move my hips gonna move my
hands aren't going in here now
[Music]
there you can see the linear
acceleration
at the eye because i'm not continuing to
turn
[Music]
but not him go around me
the bean on the outside under is going
to be weird as f to you okay
but you're doing the same thing as as
as as i start to turn it
pulls against his centrifugal
orientation okay and then the second
hand
is the same as the last one so
chew on
[Music]
so
so what i'm doing uh joedon
this is the our spiral music
just continue this
the second hand is going this this way
which makes the forearm go out okay
so i'm not going
and using the deltoid you see that
i'm going in but my body is
turning that's how i end up
on this inside and not stay on the
outside
so if i continued the hour spiral
yes boom if i continued that inward
spiral
i don't have to i don't have any other
movements
in aikido so
our spiral you see and this is the
bottom side of the
inward spiral so i don't have this
movement here
this this arm goes like this
oh and then what makes it do what you
think
the deltoid is doing i turn my body
so i'm not going like this
grip really hard
you're trying all these little tricks no
just here
and my body moves
so our spiral halfway
inverse spiral boom and
over here is inward spiral again
those are my movements those are the
movements that develop my body
so one two
three
one two three
[Music]
okay let's go
you know even when you grab it you're
not grabbing it
so let's do this one without grabbing a
hold
and i'm going to use the cross platform
hand to do the same as you should
boom i gotta get to the other side
[Music]
hey i know
guys